joining us right here on the rich eisen
show is the man who has formed the qb
summit and he is one of the top
quarterback consultants in the sport of
football good to see you in person
jordan palmer how are you sir i'm doing
great thanks for having me thanks for
being here so uh let's just jump right
into it um you've got some kids at the
collegiate level who you are counseling
and you are making better who can win
the national championship this year walk
me through the the names of the guys
that you this is interesting i mean one
congratulations on all your success i'm
not talking about this i'm talking about
michigan thank you very much
legitimately legitimate they are
legitimately legitimate huh they're not
they didn't get really lucky three weeks
the big ten's not having the worst year
ever and therefore michigan showing it i
mean it's they're legitimately good so
uh it's been awesome man cade mcnamara
has been a guy i've been around since he
was little jt daniels at georgia it's
been a very interesting
year with him getting hurt and then
stetson bennett playing at a really high
level
um i think we may end up looking back on
this defense and saying it's one of the
best defenses ever
in georgia and so jt has been a guy i
spent a lot of time with and desmond
ritter
you know as it sits right now has
finally been able to get over that hump
and be a
a non-group of five or whatever it is
where cincinnati's in there
and
so yeah it's been a blast to be able to
watch that and bryce young in alabama so
it's been it's gonna be this year it's
very quarterback heavy where the
quarterbacks are big reasons for why
things are happening and it makes it
really fun to watch so obviously it's
not a one-size-fits-all
way of grooming a quarterback it's it's
it's who they are it's what beats inside
it's obviously neck up it's the
god-given ability and so on and so forth
kate mcnamara and you said you've known
him since a kid right it was a little
guy yeah sixth grade sixth grade
honestly like probably
spend as much time with kate as any but
it just the fa the family never missed a
camp he was always he was living in reno
always coming back down by no means was
he ever the guy where you said
he's going to be you know god graced him
with he's not 6'5 he doesn't have the
craziest arm i've ever seen he doesn't
run a 4-2 uh he's just got a little
something different in him the way he
competes
uh he comports himself
not just in the moment but when a
microphone's in front of him
he just
it oozes the leadership oozes out of him
so what is his challenge to try and
you know
cash in this house money that's been
handed to the michigan wolverines right
now with that win over ohio state and
the opportunity yeah to actually take it
all right now if you think about like
what has he done well what he's done
well is handle difficult situations well
right they're not winning because he's
sprinting to his right and throwing at
60 yards across the field to his left
making crazy plays he's not turning it
over he's making great decisions um i
think he's got three or four turnover
worthy plays since he's been the starter
going back to last year i can remember
them all that's that's how they stand
out because they're they're outliers
pasted they kind of shock you when you
want to house it you're kind of like
right oh right because it's because he's
not risky with it um so i think what it
is is it's maximizing this opportunity
of it's not it's the balance of can
control those turnover worthy plays but
also when to be aggressive and that's
just something usually guys learn as
they get into the nfl um but really
cerebral really competitive really
mature kids do that well in college
kade's done that well so far in college
he's got to do that for a couple more
weeks what can you share with me what
harbaugh tells him what can you share
about a relationship between coach and
quarterback that you're willing to share
right here well i think the irony i
think the irony is kate's got a lot of
from what i don't know harbaugh as a
player i was there freshman year they
rem he's got a lot is that where the
picture are you running from no to wear
a tie to school that is definitely not
me in school no that's me as an older
man yeah uh but yeah older faster man
thank you
thank you i think from what i hear heart
about there's a lot of similarities i
mean the way that
like in 2021 kids care a lot about
perception and social media and likes
and the how things are you know
perceived like
kate doesn't it's very old school you
don't really care about instagram i
don't really care about any of that
stuff he's trying to win and so i think
what what kade was able to do is kind of
mirror what jim wanted was this all ball
don't carry about any of the other fluff
and that's who he is naturally okay
didn't have to act like that and so i
think that's two things where those guys
um again i went around jim as a player
but i see a lot of those things where
jim's jim's uh i know guys used to talk
about how he was always competitive in
these situations where they shouldn't
have been competitive like the qb
challenge right he's the guy who took it
more serious kate kind of takes
everything really seriously he competes
and everything well what is it like then
to watch a kid in jj mccarthy come
running out though how does that how
does that come into the mix so written
your conversations with cade mcnamara
would have used as an example because i
don't care who you are if you're a
competitor i want to be on the field
don't take me out well i mean pretty
much every other kid that you've
mentioned that you have playing in these
uh you know obviously jt dangers is hurt
but
you know these guys don't really come
off the field like cade does sometimes
yeah so what i use is is drew brees and
taysom hill so
drew brees got to a place in
in new orleans
i think drew got to a place where he
believed that taysom going in the in the
hill in this series at third down and
you know you've been around drew long
enough to know the competitor that drew
is yeah i don't think drew had interest
in not playing or taking a breather
but i think drew had to get to a place
where mentally he felt like jason going
in the field i'm going to get to a place
where i believe that i'm going to have a
shorter field when i go back in this is
going to be a good thing for our offense
this is going to move us it's a very
difficult thing for quarterbacks to deal
with one of the things i saw in the game
on tv last weekend jj
who i've spent time with jj i think jj's
gonna be a star it's awesome jj has a
little zone read and they had number 14
the little guy kind of stock block and
he goes down the sideline and jj drops a
dime you did right in there and there's
very slow-mo cut of a legitimate cade
pointing on where's the camera director
cade like
great ball fired up you know what i mean
and i think that's the growth where
you're going
he's so locked in on us scoring on this
drive i don't care who gets us down
there and i think you got to be able to
get there if you're going to win a
championship you're going to have a good
offense doing that but to win a
championship you've got to really get
there and i think kids there jordan
palmer here on the rich eisen show the
quarterback summit we'll talk about some
tour dates of of how you're taking your
show on the road in a moment right here
on the rich eisen show trevor lawrence
where where is he in your estimation and
how do we view his first
11 starts
in the nfl right now
you know every every rookie who ends up
playing has a different
uh
has a different start we've seen guys
start hot we've seen a ton of guys start
a lot worse than trevor really i mean
when you're the number one pick you're
taking over a team who earned the number
one pick and so you have the roster
um you know a roster that needs to be
developed and all that what i look at
trevor is how many how often
are you making the same decis the same
decisions good ones are bad ones over
and over again
um i think there are certain
interceptions that every quarterback has
to throw to know they can't throw that
ball meaning if i've got let's say a
sale route and i think i can get it over
the corner the the
cornerback but i'm not sure i did in
college i'm not sure in the league like
you throw that that corner picks it off
like okay that registers i can't that
that's not a throw i can make or back
laid across the middle on a naked
there's just those certain throws you
got to kind of do it coach can tell you
not to do it but you got to do it
feel it to be able to harness that i
don't see trevor making a lot of the
same mistakes twice
i see him
being aggressive pushing the ball down
the field trying to execute this offense
quickly roster wise they're going to
continue to evolve this is year one new
staff new everything but i just don't
see trevor making a lot of the same
mistakes over and over again which means
i see him progressing and and no at no
point did the game seem too big or too
fast or too hard or too complex so i i
think he's progressing nicely and i
don't i think everyone should be patient
well the nine losses that they have this
year matches the number of losses that
urban had in his entire tenure to us at
ohio state right now and so he's not
used to losing and neither is trevor how
how is how's he handling trevor was 86 i
think it was 86 and four high school
college combined right
so now he's lost twice the number of
games he's ever lost in his entire life
in the span of three months yeah how's
he handling that
um i think it's funny when that espn
article came out and people talked about
what does he mean he doesn't have to
compete against other people i just
think trevor is very self-confident
he knows what he knows believes what he
believes about himself and what he
believes right now and what i believe
about him is this is part of your rookie
year you got to learn whether you're 12
and 4 4 and 12 you've got to learn and
so there's so much that can happen over
the course of this first year where you
can still learn and evolve even though
it doesn't show up in stats or doesn't
show up in wins or losses so
from my perspective from across the
country watching on tv i feel like i'm
seeing him progress not make the same
mistakes twice and i don't have any
concerns about his confidence moving
okay it's not of his confidence what
about the scheme around him what about
the staff that's there i mean we're
talking you hear stuff out of
jacksonville urban
uh brought in some college guys and
there's the pro guys and there's a lot
of
bashing about that and there's your
prized prospect sitting right in the
middle of all that yeah i think one of
the things that happens and why you have
to be so mature to play quarterback at
the nfl level is you have to deal with
so many things that people like us can
sit around and speculate and talk about
you have to be able to
handle those whether you're 21 or 31.
nobody cares right once they pick you
number one or they give you a bunch of
money they don't care old you are and so
i don't know all the things that are
going on there but i would just bet on
his maturity what he's been through i
feel like being the face of college
football for a couple of years is bigger
than being the face of the jacksonville
jaguars
the magnitude of it and the eyeballs so
i just think he's so well positioned too
whatever the
good stuff that's going on whatever the
issues they're having like that's the
kind of guy you want to put in there not
somebody who's going to
kind of stir it up or put stuff out in
the public but somebody who's going to
internally handle it and develop it and
so i don't know all the stuff that's
going on in jacksonville but i just i
bet on trevor that he can kind of like
write that [ __ ] jordan palmer here on
the rich eisen show i'm sure you saw it
on thanksgiving night there was a split
screen on the nbc broadcast
of the body
angle that josh allen was throwing from
when he was in college and what he looks
like right now like where in college it
looked like he was like dwight freeny
coming around the end you know what i
mean like almost 45 degree angle right
and now he's just like as i call him
like the mandalorian standing tall back
there and firing away
what do you think he still needs to work
on as we were talking about him as an
mvp candidate coming in this season
early part of the season not so much
right now what are what are your two
cents on that if you're as a guy who's
been getting him upright and getting him
going prior to his pro career
i think i mean as good as that roster is
i know trudeau's white
time will tell how big of a loss that
was it's got to be a big one that guy's
a great player but uh that roster's
really really so that's a team that can
go all the way that's a quarterback who
can take them all the way i just think
for them it comes down to consistency
and
um that shows up in
execution and defense and tackling all
the different phases of the game so as a
quarterback you got to own all the
consistency side of it and the way that
that usually plays out is in decision
making and moving and throwing are you
doing the same things and so i think
this year um
i i don't know that his
speaking i don't know his goal was to be
it was mvp or bus i think it was super
bowl or bust and the reality is is you
can build on those and learn from it
throughout the year so josh is
continuing to evolve he showed the level
he can play at and uh as that team
continues to
kind of find this year's identity last
year it was so much diggs and josh and
right and this year other guys are
stepping up dawson knox has emerged they
don't run it though they hardly run it
you know like he's they're running back
it seems like you know with due respect
to everyone else out there
so i i i sometimes feel like so much is
put on him yeah and he feels the need to
do the proverbial do too much yeah like
is that a a real conversation to be had
between
you know quarterback guru and and
prospect 100 i think
when you play when you play quarterback
you um
you're in control of risk mitigation
running back's not running back in
fumble can make a play or can just run
into the back of the guard and get two
yards but the quarterbacks can charge
that risk mitigation right when am i
going to press it when am i going to be
a little bit more conservative and when
you get the truly competitive like the
elite competitive
like the guy that i wouldn't want to
fight competitive yeah guys um it takes
time and reps to be able to really
control that
and so in that moment okay so a couple
years ago
they i think it was the blue lead versus
desean watson and texans kind of took
some sacks tried to make a play that
wasn't there in the playoffs your
playoffs yeah like try to make a play
that wasn't there they got screwed by a
crazy uh call in the middle of overtime
as well but yes that's right no they
were blurred again no but there were
times where yes where he was in a play
it may not be there to be made right
right and so sometimes throwing the ball
out of bounds is the best possible
outcome for this play
that's been an area where i've just seen
josh
physically the side-by-side comparison
can show you but that's where i've seen
the evolution of him which is why
i had pretty high expectations for the
buffalo bills this year and they
actually despite a game or two here or
there they haven't changed for me
because i bet by the time these games
get very serious starting on monday
night that we're gonna really see that
version where no in those moments he's
making the right decision all the time
well you know belichick's gonna put him
in that position he's gonna put him in
the position of trying to take the
cheese he's gonna put him in the
position of trying to do too much he
knows exactly how to scheme that sort of
thing we have devin mccourty coming up
too i'm sure
that there's going to be certain plays
circled in that regard for sure that is
going to be the challenge on monday
night fired up for that game i can't i
mean these two teams who would have
thought that this was going to be this
relevant that guy over there yeah he's
the patriot guy over there he chose the
patriots to win their uh their division
so you know uh but yes he did he
actually did do that and you know i just
thought he was a patriot honk but now
we're seeing mac jones do what he's he's
doing right now what where does mac
jones's rookie season rank for you
seeing this
one of the best i i i don't know i don't
go off of stats a lot but my takeaway
was
and you you this will be right up your
alley watching brady at gillette this
year drive down the field and put it out
again
just watching mac jones warm up on the
sideline he just had that look and he
didn't get a chance to go back in
he just had that look on his face like
there was no question that they he was
going to come by back in and score and i
just remember telling people if i was a
patriots fan i would be stoked on how
tonight went
get the little swan song goodbye to
brady when brady came back in tampa but
your young rookie just went toe-to-toe
and had no concerns for the 20-plus year
like that's a confident dude and i i get
that he played at bama and he's an elite
11 kid he's been around it but i'm still
continually blown away
by just how quickly
mack is advancing it's
awesome it's six straight dubs for him
and
and he runs it with
incredible efficiency kurt warner said
he's doing more
in this offense in his first year than
what was asked of brady in his first
year in the offense he's doing more is
what he's yeah i would say not close for
sure
yeah i mean just the the little things
like he hit hunter henry on a little
quick little slant you watch it on tv it
looks like he threw a slant to a hunter
henry no he didn't he looked
left in a way that made number 56 run
and fall as he as he brought his eyes
back hit hunter henry out of his breath
is just the way he's manipulating
defenses with his eyes i love it most
rookies are trying to memorize the play
and then trying to memorize what their
job is and where they should go right i
just don't see mac jones doing that i
see mac jones right now
already having all that taken care of
and starting to manipulate the defense
and use his eyes in ways i just rookies
don't usually do so with the way that
the defense is playing
do you think they can win the super bowl
this year i still think it's going to be
really difficult for them to beat
buffalo in a way where they can advance
in the playoffs i think it's going to be
tough but it's just because i haven't
seen
you know this is all new new england
doing i've been watching buffalo play
really well for a couple years now
jordan palmer here on the rich eisen
show what's your diagnosis of what's
going on with baker mayfield in
cleveland
well i think
i'll say this when it comes to the draft
i think we might have talked about this
when it comes to drafting quarterbacks
guys are bus guys are not busts i
believe that teams bust on developing
the quarterback more than the player was
a bust
by the way baker may feel bad i'm not
combining those two but when we evaluate
quarterbacks did it work did it not
the times when it didn't work i think it
has more to do with what the team did to
develop now
in baker's case and a lot of guys where
i would put on that list
it he just had a lot of different things
a huge accent his first year and
then that gets fired and then freddie
kitchen takes over and then now here and
then they add in obj and
they also add in a great roster he's got
a great offensive line great run game
great defense so
it's a it's just a lot right and in that
regard it the newness of last year it
blossomed so well with stefanski and
without odell i must say but it blossoms
so well they make the playoffs they boat
race the steelers out
they go to kansas city and really gave
the chiefs a heck of a game in that
divisional round and it's just been
regressed right now it's it's been it's
been a step backwards
right and so
the consistency that you're saying that
might have been missed was actually in a
way there this year although odell was
in and then out that's the biggest
question the first couple of years it's
just hard it's just hard for me to
evaluate a guy when every year it's
completely different right
and this is now coming off of two years
where it was a lot of consistency and
haven't seen them take that next step i
was pretty surprised i thought i thought
they'd be rolling on offense you know i
thought their ability to run the ball
and play action and
look baker's baker's accurate he can
push the ball down the field he's proven
that scott was a walk-on twice in the
heisman finals three times i mean i
don't i'm not wondering whether or not
he can throw it but i am wondering what
that piece is
that has not allowed them to yeah you
know continue to grow from last year so
are we great i know the general manager
andrew berry said today that there's a
something missing in the passing game
the passing game is not firing right now
and of course you look at the
quarterback for that sort of thing
so
when you whatever film you do see of
baker what are you seeing that's either
firing or not uh you know i mean what
like what is what is
what is it
for brown's fans to kind of hang their
hat on who are certainly some browns
fans are saying let's get case keenum
out there right now what do you think
from what you might be i haven't studied
them too much what i will say is
what you have to be able to do in this
league at an elite level if you're going
to continue to progress is you have to
be able to throw into tight windows from
tight spaces
and that's something where i've i've
always wondered because he didn't do it
a lot at oklahoma because of the system
it was really good dudes were wide open
we look at who he was thrown to kind of
all went first or second round all right
mark andrews was this tight end
hollywood these different guys so that
it's throwing from tight spaces into
tight windows
we were talking about cade mcnamara from
michigan earlier yes that's what he's
done well this year it's not the crazy
place it's tight spaces tight windows
that's been a thing for baker where i
evaluate a lot of these guys coming in
and if they haven't done it in college
maybe they just didn't weren't put in a
position to do it doesn't mean they
can't i think that would probably be the
one area that i would point to ago i
don't know that i've seen a ton of
progression there doesn't mean that it's
not gonna progress
everyone's gonna miss a deep ball every
now and then that happens but it's that
throwing from tight windows throwing
into tight windows from tight spaces
typically bigger guys have an easier job
with it but at some point everybody's
got to be able to do that because that's
how most third downs
so i think the question is because part
of the issue for baker is he's drafted
first overall in a draft that does
include again one of your clients and
josh allen and lamar jackson who are
just phenomenal and guys who can say i'm
taking it over
i'm taking it over with my legs and my
arm that's what i'm going to do and i'm
going to win games and lamar won an mvp
in that way and he's even better passing
now
so is it possible in this day and age
that somebody can have that blossoming
mop this it doesn't have to be both ways
two ways with arms and legs but just a
blossoming into
dynamic franchise taking it over no
matter what's going on on defense or
running game tonight for somebody to do
that in years five through eight of
their nfl career 100 100
so
we what's happened is from uh media and
fans and fantasy football and instant
gratification i didn't know right now
right and we were so quick to cast guys
out aside you know second year he's not
even he's not even good
development doesn't have a timeline
right we can create a timeline and say
well if they don't
if they're not good by year three then
right based off contracts but
i mean my brother had a great run in
cincinnati and then it was tough for a
while in oakland and then you know bruce
arians and larry fitzgerald and the
right pieces and all of a sudden poofy's
in the nfc championship runner up for
mvp
that was like year 12 right right uh
alex smith's his best statistical year
was in kansas city
after seven coordinators in san
francisco i think it was legitimately
seven coordinated san francisco well
yeah because he had got to a place where
it wasn't just he had good white outs
the development had peaked and matched
what's around him so i just guys who are
two three four years in who haven't had
success yet i just think it's way too
early to throw in the towel i want to
see them in a good situation
and before i evaluate i just have a hard
time evaluating somebody in a bad
situation so then put it in a point is
is is baker in a bad situation right now
no i think the first couple of years was
any number one pick is going to have is
gonna have a lot of turnover and a lot
of that stuff but no i think this last
year and a half has been a good
situation from again not in the locker
room i don't know the ramifications and
stuff but um yeah i think it's a
situation where you could go yeah you'd
want to see some success out of this and
how about cleveland with him
you but you think cleveland should stick
with him you know they're at that point
in time of you know
having to give a long-term deal and
stuff like that what do you think of
that front i don't know if i have an
opinion on that i would just always err
on the side of if you have invested a
lot of i don't even care about the money
because you're putting you're spending
the money one way or another right right
yeah right invested this much time and
resources and reps and built around it
i i'm i always are on the side of give
it another year right like just because
everyone else is impatient do we think
this guy can what are the issues do we
think we can get him there
and if we can let's invest in those
resources the side by side of josh allen
used to throw throw now
they put great resources around them
they are open to all of it they hired a
great quarterback coach in ken dorsey
they they weren't concerned with how
many people
haven't improved accuracy yes they built
brandon being built something to improve
the accuracy
so uh before i let you go the qb summits
coming to potentially a town near
everybody listening and watching yeah i
i always ran camps out here and it's
been awesome and uh when coveted it made
it tough before and so yeah i'm gonna do
a tour around the country 12 stops 10
cities and i'm gonna announce it next
week and run it like a tour where can
people find out when you announce it
next week um it'll be uh on qbsummit.com
qbsummit.com and what does that mean
coming to town like you can come out i
run camps i keep them at 40. i take all
the stuff that i do with older guys yeah
but it's for 10 to 17 year olds okay
i've ran probably 30 of these um locally
over the last few years sure and have
just ramped it up and and uh and made it
really cool and and uh it's just it's
really kind of more of like a
transformative thing it's a weekend
where they're gonna get exposure to what
it really takes to play quarterback and
the tools to be able to do it instead of
a bunch of drones 10 to 17 year olds
let's go let's develop and let's let's
go young so you'll be able to say like
i'm getting old because i got a bunch of
like players whose kids come
now who's that we got well i got my my
brother's kid
mark burnell's boys josh mccown's boys
like just these other like these players
there's more accounts there's more
accounts how many more accounts can win
no hey luke's got some baller sons
i bet little owen's a baller i bet so
you'll be able to come on this show
years from now and like you just said
about cade mac i've known him since the
sixth grade yeah wow
uh at uh
so you go to qbeatsummit.com
and you can follow jordanpalmer on
twitter at jwpoms i do it you should as
well good to see you here sir hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here